wait is this like the Venus flytrap is
that what that is or what's that thing
called I think it's a Venus fly yeah I
like that you're wearing it thank you
that's like great metaphorically
speaking when you meet people yeah it's
like I'll eat you up yeah welcome back I
have to ask you every time we have here
I ask you about your pole dancing
because you're like getting really good
at it I'm not you're not no I saw your
video your latest video no no I'm pretty
well that's really hard it's hard but
I'm so bad I have tried and I was like
some things aren't meant for me listen
yeah Kelly it is okay to be bad at stuff
oh I'm amazingly trying to normalize
being bad at things you like like I have
fun but like by no means am I sexy I
truly like well I don't agree with that
oh come on I don't agree with that Miss
white boots I saw that post my
and like I could not physically do that
oh yeah
[Applause]
that's a workout it isn't working that
is a workout look at her catching
herself on the like I can't do that well
I also narrate I like to narrate my
videos just so everyone knows what's
going on it's just like oh she's
breathing heavy oh she's tired uh oh
will she make it up the poll probably
not
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]